regarde du
coin de la salle de bains et donc ses
acquis sûrement une de mes patientes
normandie gériatre oui bah je sais pas
alors sénat c'est à toi ça non le redis
on se protège en plus de pikes peak
horrible c'est pas toi ça il sait quoi
ça mais [ __ ] mais c'est dégueulasse
non c'est pas cool biz et max alors et
maxime jamie lynn meuf qui fait de la
musique de chambre et du pilat qui
s'arrange toujours pour être cernée par
des notes sous m mais c'est parce que ça
il a une sensibilité
singulière bien sûr
[Musique]
et je n'avais pas cette marque je suis
parfois demandé john sutcliffe tous ses
scores
voilà c'est pas comme ça deux ans
quand tu deviens maire la première fois
quand tu deviens une maman dit
tu joues à l'adulte
vision latérale
force de faire semblant
au sud et un adulte je suis complètement
défoncée ses heures tu m'apprends le
rolland du corps tu perds tu l'as
toujours
on ressente wayma une famille heureuse
on a une jolie famille hinault
je faisais trop de temps libre on
retrouve des occupations madame question
des loisirs enfants nous lâcher un peu
[Musique]